Phải khắc khốn nước lớn lục tùng chân nhà, kéo theo thắc nước nổ xuống sản nhà gà tê ba sân vai quốc tế tại Indonesia.
Sư việc sả chêu sấu tháng từ tại sân vai quốc tế sau cano hát tà lưỡng nhất thủ đô ra cắt tà.
Mưa lớn khi nước thống qua mãi tại nhà gà tê ba, dô lại thành một biệm chúng trên chần,
áp lực nước tăng dần, đẹ lên làm biến sạm chân nhà, trước khi vỡ tùng tạo thành giống nước sả thằng xuống sản,
khi nhiều hành khách vội bán nế cháng xưa tắn độ đặc.
Bảo New Street Times rất lời đại diện sân vai cho biết, sự việc kéo dài khoảng năm phút không khi nhận thương tích.
Nhưng viên sân vai đã nhìn chống dọn dẹp và phong tỏa khu bực để đảm bảo hỏi đậu sân vai không bị gián bản.
Một số chuyến bay phải chuyến hướng giòn mưa tò và giòn lớn trong cung ngày.
Nhà gà tê ba khánh thành từ năm 2020, tiếp nhận chính các chuyến khúc tế tại sân vai xu cano hát tà,
nơi đã đón cần năm 2019, lợn khách năm 2020, lớn thứ 3 tại đồng năm á.
Thời tiếp cực rwan gồm mưa tò zò lớn đang chẳng xuống Indonesia từ ngày 30 tư đến chiến thân tư khiến một số quốc vực tại thú đô ra các tăng ngập phong,
chính quyền đã phát kẹn bảo đến người dân càng giác chẳng những lời quy hiệm.